okay so i get not reading ahead of the
show but couldn't you at least have read
up to where they've gotten so far hell
no all that's gonna do is bring to buy
all the stuff that got left behind Game
of Thrones is already massively dense
wonderfully layered I don't need to find
out all the stuff that could have been
that I'm not getting to see once the
show's over maybe I'll crack open the
books no you won't shut up you won't
though you don't know that yeah I do
you're lazy you'll be happy with the
product you have you'll go back and
watch the entire show from beginning to
end it before you ever crack open one of
the book which reminds me we have figure
we're gonna marathon the first four
seasons before the new one gets going
are you two gonna submit this time pass
book snobs like you said why do I need
the watered-down version when I've got
the real thing not awesome I'm
paraphrasing your words and making a
better point let it go man she's all
high and mighty because she knows where
this is going I just can't wait for you
guys to meet Lady Stoneheart come Cathy
they're not doing her shut up seriously
yeah I don't even know that is but I
remember the producers made a point of
making that clear after the last season
ended but they kid apparently they can
and they did but that's like cutting
peeves out of the Harry Potter movies or
tom bombadil a lot of lord of rings
that's not the same thing apparently it
is I guess she's not as vital as you
thought she was gonna be look chart
george RR martin has been tight with the
guys making the show and i think they
know enough about the future to know
that they can cut her and be just fine
you know actually a couple years
we're gonna be left behind completely
anyways it's true not listening okay
maybe maybe winds of winter will come
out before they've exhausted all of book
five but there's no way that dream of
spring will be done before the show
catches up everyone involved has
admitted as much oh the book snobs get
scooped by the lowly medium of TV okay
you're getting worked up so I'm
suspending all talk on this topic
besides your etching into spoilers and I
haven't even read the books yet are you
ever going to maybe I like you trying to
convince me so um who's ladies don't zip
it yep wait why are we not getting back
share my pain puny mortal